un réveillon à 1000 francs pour 6
personnes c'est le défi qu'ont relevé
pour nous quatre jeunes chefs après
pascal barbot hier installé dans le 16e
arrondissement de paris
mais voici nicolas le bec 28 ans à peine
et déjà un très beau parcours
après avoir travaillé dans les cuisines
des frères pourcel à montpellier d'alain
passard à paris il dirige aujourd'hui la
cour des loges à lyon où claude crespo
et pierre moscovite l'ont rencontré ces
deux superbes essais la connotation
presque japonaise est aussi une création
de nicolas le bec qui nous propose comme
menu de fête pommes de terre compte de
finges châtaignes de merde l'écart dans
la cuillère aux champignons et du fort
de deux sangliers pourquoi rosa la
mettra bouge et topinambours à la
fourchette fèves de cacao au beurre salé
et feuilles d'argent suprême chercher de
la presle en même temps les localités
ce jeune chef de 28 ans et son marché au
téléphone il est vrai qu'outre ce
restaurant lyonnais
il dirige sept autres établissements
dans trois régions de france
d'où une gestion de son temps très
organisé j'ai depuis cinq ans dénicher
un certain nombre de fournisseurs qui
sont non de 60 pour pour cibler et pour
avoir mes yeux finalement donc ils
achètent et j'achète en toute confiance
et savent que si ça me convient pas
c'est un retour à l'envoyeur
pour le premier plat une croûte de sel
qui deviendra un ramequin en forme
d'oeuf tatis et de foin à l'intérieur de
la purée de pommes de terre persillées
surmonté de cherbourg saint en boîte
avec couronner le tout un jus de
crevettes grises
dépenses somptuaires 80 pour les patates
8 francs pour les ours à une recette
accompagné d'un vin blanc à 22 francs
pour les produits plus rare nicolas se
déplacer c'est pour lui une récréation
aujourd'hui il cherche une herbe
asiatique le noga qui rendent à la
préparation du 2e place en harmonie avec
le légume régional les cardons ces
plantes frotter de citron sont coupées
et simplement revenu tout comme les
champignons ces derniers avec du persil
et quelques brins de nogaye la note
originale intervient avec cd de moelle
osseuse aussi simplement revenu et pour
finir la farce des oignons qui on frise
aussi dans deux villes de l'île vierge
pour le montage final
la farce une tranche de foie gras à
peine saisi une tranche de moelle et de
feuilles de chou aux eu l'air c'est le
sanglier qui revient le plus cher dans
ce réveillon 300 francs de viande en
tout pour 6 700 francs y compris 132,20
150 francs de champagne pari gagné pour
nicolas qu en fait seule l'innovation
excite chaque fois j'ai réalisé un plat
qui menace déjà je le termine j'aime les
jeux pas sur autre chose on capable je
laisse en place il m'a vraiment convenu
au départ et je fais là je le laisse la
main mais mes collègues qui vont les
faire de façon à le proposer sur mes
cartes
enfin ce jeune chef qui ne dort que
trois heures par nuit et qui toujours et
vêtus de noir ont passé inaperçu se
double d'un poète spontanée il ne laisse
à personne le soin de composer ses
bouquets de fleurs